This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. If you live or work in a city, sitting in traffic is probably a big part of your life. It's about 15 to 20 to 30 out in the inbound side. We had about 20 minutes of life. Here in Washington, DC, we take perverse pride in having some of the worst traffic in the United States. But on a global scale, DC has nothing on London, or Istanbul, Rio, or Mexico City. On today's episode, we're going to explore all kinds of interventions that can make traffic better. We're also going to look at the interventions that are supposed to make traffic better, but don't. I feel like we should put together the international journal of unintended consequences
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。如果你在城市里生活或工作，深陷交通拥堵可能占了你生活很大一部分。进城方向大约要花15、20或30分钟。我们大概有20分钟的时间。在华盛顿特区，我们因拥有美国最糟糕的交通而有一种扭曲的自豪感。但在全球范围内，华盛顿的交通跟伦敦、伊斯坦布尔、里约热内卢或墨西哥城比起来根本不算什么。在今天的节目中，我们将探讨各种能够改善交通状况的干预措施。我们还将探讨那些本该改善交通却毫无作用的干预措施。我觉得我们应该汇编一本《国际意想不到后果期刊》，
and send them to lawmakers all over the planet. Before we get there, we want to take you on a quick trip around some of the world's most congested cities. Producer Maggie Penman reached out to NPR correspondent station in Asia, Africa, and Europe. She's also going to tell us about a little traffic culture clash of her own. So a few years ago, I'm out in LA for a couple of days for work. I'm driving a rented car, and I come up to a busy intersection. And I'm trying to turn left. I have my blinker on.
然后把它寄给全球各地的立法者。在那之前，我们想带大家快速游览世界上几个交通最拥堵的城市。制片人玛吉·彭曼联系了美国国家公共电台（NPR）驻亚洲、非洲和欧洲的记者站。她还将跟我们讲述她自己遭遇的一场交通文化冲突。所以几年前，我去洛杉矶出差几天。我开着一辆租来的车，来到一个繁忙的十字路口。我正试图左转。我打着转向灯。
I'm in the left-hand turn lane, and the light is green. But there are still tons of cars coming through the intersection, so I patiently sit there waiting my turn and the light turns yellow and there's still cars coming through the intersection and then the light turns red. I think, okay, I'll just wait until the light turns green again. Big mistake. The cars behind me start honking like crazy. I can see the guy in my rearview mirror and he's losing it, yelling, hitting his steering wheel and frustration. When the light does turn green again, I'm now determined to make this left turn. And the guy behind me turns too and then passes me immediately, yelling out his window
我处于左转车道上，灯是绿色的。但十字路口依然车流如织，所以我耐心地坐在车里等待转弯的时机，接着灯变黄了，十字路口依然有车通过，然后灯变成了红心。我想，好吧，我等到绿灯亮了再走。大错特错。我后面的车开始疯狂按喇叭。我能从后视镜里看到那个家伙快气疯了，大喊大叫，沮丧地拍打着方向盘。当灯再次变绿时，我下定决心要完成这次左转。我后面的那家伙也转了弯，然后立刻超过了我，摇下车窗大喊大叫，
and flipping the off. At the next intersection, the woman who was behind him pulls up next to me and signals for me to roll my window down, and she's this kind looking lady probably about my mother's age, and I thought she was going to commiserate with me about how crazy that guy was. But no, then she starts yelling at me too. Why didn't you go? Were you texting? What's wrong with you? So I get to the MPR West office, and I'm very shaken up, and I describe this experience to a couple of my colleagues who live in work in LA and they're both like, oh yeah, you probably should have gone.
还向我竖中指。在下一个路口，他后面的那个女人把车开到我旁边，示意我摇下车窗。她是一个看起来很和善的女士，大概我母亲的年纪，我以为她会跟我一样，痛骂刚才那个家伙太疯狂了。但并没有，接着她也开始冲我大喊大叫。你怎么不走？你刚才在发短信吗？你有毛病吧？于是我到了NPR西部办公室，心情非常激荡，我把这段经历讲给几位在洛杉矶生活和工作的同事听，他们的反应都是：“哦，对，你当时大概应该直接开过去。”
So we confirmed for you that you are indeed crazy, at least in LA you are. That's Arzurezvani, an editor at Morning Edition who works out of MPR's LA Bureau. She was one of the people I was meeting that day and I recently called her up to try and get some insight about why my style of driving was so frustrating to L.A. drivers. You have to kind of float in the middle of an intersection when you want to make a left or right turn. You got to wait for the cars, uncommon traffic to you know finish up and sometimes that means making that turn on a red. So wait, I was supposed to run the red light? By the book, that's illegal, right? But there's just a new normal that is introduced in cities like Los Angeles, and you just
所以我们向你证实了，你的确挺疯狂的，至少在洛杉矶是这样。说话的是阿尔祖·雷兹瓦尼，《早间新闻》的一名编辑，在NPR洛杉矶记者站工作。她是我那天见过的人之一，我最近给她打了电话，想了解一下为什么我的驾驶风格会让洛杉矶的司机如此抓狂。当你想左转或右转时，你得把车悬停在十字路口中间。你得等对向行驶的车辆开过去，你知道的，等它们走完，有时这意味着得在红灯时转弯。等等，我是说我应该闯红灯？按规矩来说，这违法对吧？但在洛杉矶这样的城市里，这是一种新常态，你只能
kind of got to go with the flow. I was really curious about this new normal that Arzu was talking about, and I wondered whether other cities had unspoken rules or conventions too. When you come to a light and it turns green, the automatic thing to do if you want to take a left turn is to immediately rush and take a left across three or four lanes of traffic. The first person I thought to ask was Frank Langfit, who in addition to being Emperor's correspondent based in Shanghai, has also occasionally driven a taxi around the city to find stories. It's like being in a game where anything can come at you at any time from any angle. So a stop sign, a light, is not entirely relevant but not very relevant.
顺应潮流。我对阿尔祖所说的那种新常态感到十分好奇，我也想知道其他城市是否也有不成文的规则或惯例。当你来到红绿灯路口，灯变绿时，如果你想左转，你的第一反应就是立刻冲过去，横穿三四条车道的车流。我第一个想到的就是弗兰克·兰格夫，他除了是NPR驻上海记者外，有时还会在市内开出租车来寻找新闻线索。这感觉就像在一场游戏中，任何东西都可能随时从任何角度朝你袭来。所以停车标志、交通信号灯，并不是完全相关，但也算不上非常相关。
So when I go through intersections, I look right, I look left, I look right again. The norm in Shanghai is that traffic laws are more like suggestions. Here in Shanghai, there is not a lot of enforcement and I'm amazed when I get a ticket. I was pulled over a while ago for being in the wrong turn lane, which was just kind of comical, considering all the things that the cops allow people to do here. But considering all of this, I was shocked when Frank told me about another norm. There's almost no road rage. As long as the car is never touch, people just let it go.
因此，当我通过十字路口时，我会看右边，看左边，再看一遍右边。在上海，交通法规更像是建议，这种现象很普遍。在上海，执法力度并不大，每当我收到罚单时都会感到很惊讶。我前不久因为走错车道被拦下过，考虑到这里警察允许人们做的各种事情，这简直有点滑稽。但考虑到这一切，当弗兰克告诉我另一个不成文的规矩时，我惊呆了。这里几乎没有路怒症。只要车没有擦碰到，大家就算了。
And I think it's maybe it's partly a function. I don't understand all of this even though I've been here a long time. It may be a function if this is such a crowded country, especially these big cities on these coast, that if you were going to get angry about this stuff, you'd just have a heart attack. In fact, he said, I'm the only one who has road rage. I'm like, I'm like, I'm like the only guy in the city who has road rage.
我想这可能部分原因在于……虽然我在这里住了很久，但我还是搞不懂这一切。这可能是因为这是一个人口如此拥挤的国家，尤其是沿海这些大城市，如果你要为这种事情生气，你早就心脏病发作了。事实上他说，我是唯一一个有路怒症的人。我感觉自己就像、我感觉自己就像是这个城市里唯一一个有路怒症的人。
I also talked to MPR's correspondent in Nairobi, Greg Warner, and he told me Nairobi is one of the most polite cities he's ever lived in. For instance, nobody cuts in line. But when it comes to driving, Greg says, all that changes. One of the main features of driving in Nairobi, according to Greg, is that there are very few traffic lights. There are occasionally, like a random traffic light you'll see, but nobody actually pays
我还跟NPR驻内罗毕记者格雷格·华纳聊了聊，他告诉我内罗毕是他住过的最有礼貌的城市之一。例如，没有人会插队。但说到开车时，格雷格说，情况就全变了。据格雷格介绍，在内罗毕开车的主要特点之一是几乎没有红绿灯。偶尔会有，比如你会看到一个随机的红绿灯，但实际上根本没人理会
attention to it. It has no actual meaning. It just turns green and red and there are no particular reasons. So how do people know when to go? It's all convention. And so in this situation, what I would think people would do is a kind of honor system. Like, okay, yeah, you went, okay, now let me go.
它没有任何实际意义。它只是绿灯亮、红灯亮，并没有什么特别的原因。那人们怎么知道什么时候该走呢？全靠惯例。所以在这种情况下，我认为人们会采取某种荣誉制度。就像是，好吧，你走过了，现在轮到我走了。
That lane hasn't gone for a while. Like, it's just a kind of understanding, but it's actually just a complete free for all. Everybody's trying to go at once. And every foreland intersection is like a gridlock. And it's not just a gridlock where you know, some cars will kind of inch forward. But it's like a twisted knot where I'm behind your bumper and they're behind their bumper. And it's like this interlocked, you know, kind of origami
那个车道已经好久没车通过了。这就好比是一种默契，但实际上它完全是个各凭本事的乱局。每个人都想同时通过。每一个四车道十字路口都堵得水泄不通。而且这不仅仅是那种某些车会慢慢往前蹭的拥堵。它就像一个扭曲的死结，我的车头紧贴着你的车尾，别人的车头紧贴着别人的车尾。这就像是一种相互咬合的、你知道的，类似折纸
or whatever. I also talked to Rich Preston, NPR's producer in London. And the primary feature of driving in the UK is of course that you drive on the left. And as the London producer dealing with visiting American correspondence, I see this a lot, is visitors to the United Kingdom stepping out into the road, not looking down the road the right way. Rich travels around for work and is pretty custom to switching sides and driving on the right, but occasionally that rule of thumb gets him into trouble.
或者别的东西。我还采访了NPR驻伦敦制片人里奇·普雷斯顿。在英国开车的最大特点当然是靠左行驶。作为应对来访美国记者的伦敦制片人，我经常看到这种情况：去英国访问的游客走到马路上时，看路的方向全反了。里奇因为工作原因四处奔波，已经习惯了切换车道并靠右行驶，但偶尔这种经验法则还是会给他带来麻烦。
There's that mentality of, oh I mean another country I'm going to have to drive on the right hand side, that I started driving on the right hand side of the road in Ireland, even though it should have been sticking on the left. And even when he's back home in London, Rich says driving can be pretty scary. Because the thing about London is it's such an old city, it's really hard to make more space for all the people that are here. Rich mostly cycles around the city these days, but he can still be found honking at drivers. I actually bought a horn for my bike, which is this small thing that clips onto the handlebars and it's an kind of electronic horn and it's about 140 decibels and it saved my life
有一种心态是，“哦，我在另一个国家，我得靠右行驶”，结果我在爱尔兰开始靠道路右侧行驶，尽管我本该坚持靠左。而且即使回到伦敦的家中，里奇说开车也可能会非常吓人。因为伦敦的问题在于它是一座历史悠久的城市，很难为这里的居民腾出更多空间。里奇现在主要在城里骑自行车出行，但你有时依然能听到他冲司机按喇叭。我其实为我的自行车买了一个喇叭，这是一个可以夹在车把上的小东西，是一个电子喇叭，大约有140分贝，它曾
on so many occasions I can guarantee you. I asked Rich to collect some sound of his commute home yesterday so I'm going to leave you on this somewhat shrill note. Watch, real note. Whee! Whee! Whee! Whee! Whee! Alright, hope you made it home safely.
在很多次情况下拯救了我的生命，我向你保证。我让里奇收集了他昨天通勤回家的声音，所以我要用这段多少有点刺耳的声音来结束今天的节目。注意，真实的音频。呜！呜！呜！呜！呜！好了，希望大家平安到家。
That's Hidden Brain Producer Maggie Penman. After a short break, Dan Pink is going to be back on the show to play around a stopwatch science with me. We're going to tell you about interesting social science research on what works and doesn't work to fix traffic congestion. They found even controlling for population growth that constructing additional roads led to more traffic congestion, not less.
那是《隐藏的大脑》制片人玛吉·彭曼。短暂休息之后，丹·平克将重返节目，和我一起探讨秒表科学。我们将为您介绍有趣的社会科学研究，看看哪些方法对治理交通拥堵管用，哪些不管用。他们发现，即使控制了人口增长因素，建设更多的道路也会导致交通拥堵加剧，而不是减少。
Stay with us. Stay with us. Stay with us. Back now for another round of stop-watch science. I'm Shankar Vidantum. I'm joined as always by Daniel Pink, our senior stopwatch science correspondent. Welcome, Dad. Thank you, Shankar.
请继续收听。请继续收听。请继续收听。欢迎回到新一期的秒表科学。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。与往常一样，加入我的还有丹·平克，我们的资深秒表科学记者。欢迎你，丹。谢谢你，尚卡尔。
On stopwatch science, Dan and I give one another 60 seconds to summarize interesting social science research. As we approach the 60 second mark, our producers will drown us out with music just like they do at the Oscars. Our topic today is traffic. You hate it, you deal with it, maybe you are even in it right now. Today we're going to explore what works and what doesn't work in easy congestion and improving traffic safety.
在秒表科学环节中，我和丹会给对方60秒的时间来总结有趣的社会科学研究。当我们接近60秒大关时，我们的制作人就会用音乐盖过我们的声音，就像他们在奥斯卡颁奖典礼上做的那样。我们今天的主题是交通。你讨厌它，你必须应付它，说不定你现在正身处车流之中。今天我们将探讨在缓解交通拥堵和提高交通安全方面，什么方法管用，什么方法不管用。
Dan, if you're ready, your first 60 seconds starts now. Well, there's one easy, if expensive solution, and that's just to build more roads, right? Makes sense. Well, maybe not. Two economists writing in the American Economic Review analyzed two decades worth of data on US commuting times and road construction. They found even controlling for population growth that constructing additional roads led to more traffic congestion, not less.
丹，如果你准备好了，你的前60秒现在开始。好吧，有一个简单却昂贵的解决方案，那就是多修路，对吧？听起来很有道理。嗯，也许并不尽然。两位在《美国经济评论》上发表文章的经济学家分析了长达二十年的美国通勤时间和道路建设数据。他们发现，即使控制了人口增长，建设更多的道路也会导致交通拥堵加剧，而不是减少。
Now what's going on here? Even though this paper is a complex bear of statistical analysis, the core explanation is simple. Supply and demand. When we build roads, we increase the supply of driving opportunities, increasing the supply of something generally reduces its price. But driving it turns out is extremely responsive to price changes. The lower price, that is more room on the roads, increases demand again.
这到底是是怎么回事？尽管这篇论文包含了复杂的统计分析，但核心解释很简单：供求关系。当我们修建道路时，我们增加了驾驶机会的供给，而某种东西供给的增加通常会降低其价格。但事实证明，驾驶行为对价格变化极为敏感。价格降低（即道路上的空间增加）再次刺激了需求。
More individuals and commercial truckers now want to drive and they recongest the roads. Economists call it the fundamental law of highway congestion. More roads cause more traffic. Unfortunately policy makers ignore the law and the result is futility. So I'm guessing the solution to this is more public transit you would think but what the research also shows is that adding public transportation also increases congestion for the exact same reason it lowers the price of driving driving response to price changes more people then get on the roads so more public transit doesn't help more roads don't help we just have to resign ourselves a traffic jams well what we have to do is i think we have
更多的个人和货车司机现在想要开车，他们再次造成了道路拥堵。经济学家称之为公路拥堵的基本定律。更多的道路导致更多的交通。不幸的是，决策者忽视了这一规律，结果只能是徒劳无功。所以我猜解决这个问题的办法是发展更多的公共交通，你可能会这么想，但研究同时表明，增加公共交通也会加剧拥堵，原因完全相同：它降低了驾驶成本，驾驶行为对价格变化做出反应，于是更多的人上了路。所以增加公共交通帮不上忙，修路也帮不上忙，我们只能听天由命地接受交通堵塞了。好吧，我们必须做的是，我认为我们必须
to start thinking like economists and realize how much driving depends on price and so the best thing to do is something that is deeply politically in popular which is to raise the price of driving perhaps through congestion charges or higher tolls i think that being just a quick president and i suspect he's not going to win no i don't think so. But maybe you can win, Shankar, on your next 60 seconds, which begins right now. All right. When you enact laws or make policies that affect human beings, it's often easy to forget
开始像经济学家一样思考，认识到驾驶行为在多大程度上取决于价格，所以最好的做法是采取一项极其不受政治欢迎的举措，那就是提高驾驶成本，或许可以通过征收拥堵费或提高通行费来实现。我觉得作为总统候选人，他这番话肯定赢不了，我猜他不会胜选。不，我也这么觉得。不过尚卡尔，说不定你能在接下来的60秒里获胜，计时现在开始。好的。当你颁布法律或制定影响人类的政策时，往往很容易忘记
that you're dealing with a dynamic system, which is exactly what you were just talking about, Dan. People adapt to new rules often in ways that policymakers don't anticipate. In the late 1980s, Mexico City was dealing with a pollution problem. Lawmaker said, let's pass a new law. They banned drivers from the road one day each week. The day you were not allowed to drive was calculated based on the last digits of your car license plate number. Boom, once in a whole law, 20% fewer cars in the road each day, right?
你面对的是一个动态系统，丹，这正是你刚才所谈论的。人们对新规则的适应方式往往是政策制定者始料未及的。在20世纪80年代末，墨西哥城正在应对污染问题。立法者说，让我们通过一项新法律吧。他们禁止司机每周有一天开车上路。你被禁止开车的那一天是根据你车牌号的最后一位数字计算出来的。轰，这一招真管用，每天路上的汽车减少了20%，对吧？
What could go wrong? Exactly. Lucas Davis at the University of Michigan finds that pollution did not decline as a result of the measure in Mexico City. Why drivers went out and bought more cars? If I can't drive my Toyota on Mondays, I'm going to drive my Chevy instead. Even worse, the law triggered an increase in older, more polluting cars, perhaps because buying a new car is expensive, so drivers bought an old gas gas-linked clunker to drive the one day of the week they could not use their regular car. I feel that lawmakers around the world should be asked to sign the Hippocratic Oath Dan. First, do, no, hard.
会有什么问题呢？一点没错。密歇根大学的卢卡斯·戴维斯发现，墨西哥城的污染并没有因为这项措施而减少。为什么？司机们纷纷出门购买了更多的汽车。如果我周一不能开我的丰田车，那我就改开雪佛兰。更糟糕的是，这项法律引发了对更旧、污染更严重汽车的需求增加，可能是因为买新车很贵，所以司机们买了一辆尾气排放超标的破旧老车，用来在他们不能开常规汽车的那一天代步。我觉得应该要求全世界的立法者签署希波克拉底誓言，丹。首先，别作恶。
Exactly, right. I feel like we should put together the international journal of unintended consequences and send them to law makers all over the planet indeed that's what this is indeed now hoping that the consequences of the next sixty seconds are predictable then your time starts now we all know traffic exhaust and air pollution are harmful but what about traffic noise is it a health hazard or just an annoyance? A team of British researchers looked at data on 8.6 million people in neighborhoods across London.
完全正确。我觉得我们应该汇编一本《国际意想不到后果期刊》，然后把它寄给全球各地的立法者，事实上，这就是这本书的用意。现在，希望接下来的60秒所带来的后果是可以预测的，你的时间现在开始。我们都知道汽车尾气和空气污染有害健康，但交通噪音呢？它是一种健康危害还仅仅是一种滋扰？一组英国研究人员查阅了伦敦各地社区860万人口的数据。
Then they analyzed their exposure to daytime and nighttime traffic noise and compared that to a range of health data. What they found even after controlling for race, sex, air pollution levels, socioeconomic status, and other factors was sobering. Adults exposed to long-term daytime road traffic noise had lower life expectancies and were more likely to be admitted to the hospital for strokes than people living in quieter areas. This was especially true for elderly residents.
然后他们分析了这些人对白天和夜间交通噪音的暴露情况，并将其与一系列健康数据进行了对比。他们发现，即使在控制了种族、性别、空气污染水平、社会经济地位和其他因素之后，结果依然令人清醒。长期暴露在白天道路交通噪音中的成年人，其预期寿命更短，因中风住院的可能性也比生活在安静地区的人更高。老年居民尤其如此。
Now the researchers found only a correlation and the effect wasn't huge. But other evidence has shown that constantly being around loud traffic triggers stress hormones, which are linked to hypertension and occasionally death. Bottom line, that racket you hear in certain areas of big cities, honking, idling, revving, may be harming people who aren't even in the cars. So interesting, Dan, is it possible that this is being driven just by the fact that you
研究人员发现的只是一种相关性，且影响并非巨大。但其他证据表明，长期身处嘈杂的交通环境中会引发应激激素，这与高血压以及偶尔发生的死亡有关。总而言之，你在大城市某些区域听到的那种喧嚣——按喇叭、怠速空转、轰油门——可能会伤害甚至不在车内的人。太有趣了，丹，有没有可能这只是因为你
have more noise pollution in urban areas, and they may be other factors in urban areas that increase the mortality rate? Well, possibly, but they actually did a good job of controlling for a lot of that. They divided up the city into census tracks and actually compared census tracks to each other, and the census tracks that had more noise had worse health outcomes. Again, even after you control for the things we know drive health outcomes, especially socioeconomic status. So there was something about noise that seemed to be producing these ill effects.
身处城市地区，那里的噪音污染更多，而城市地区可能还存在其他增加死亡率的因素？嗯，有可能，但他们在控制许多这类因素方面确实做得很好。他们把城市划分成不同的普查区，并将普查区之间进行对比，结果发现噪音更大的普查区的健康状况更差。同样，即使在你控制了我们所知的会影响健康状况的因素（尤其是社会经济地位）之后依然如此。因此，噪音似乎确实会带来这些不良影响。
So let me turn it over to you for your 60 seconds, but I'd like you in light of the study to do it very quietly. All right, so we've heard that noise can be bad for you, but can making noise also save your life. James Habir Imana and William Jack at Georgetown University analyzed two interventions in Kenya to improve traffic safety. The government passed a set of laws to limit unsafe driving among many bus drivers. These are vans that hold
那么，接下来把时间交给你进行你的60秒，但我希望结合这项研究，你保持非常安静地完成它。好吧，我们已经听说噪音对健康有害，但制造噪音也能救你的命吗？乔治城大学的詹姆斯·哈比尔·伊马纳和威廉·杰克分析了肯尼亚旨在提高交通安全的两项干预措施。政府通过了一系列法律，旨在限制众多小巴司机的危险驾驶行为。这些是可以容纳
a dozen passengers. They are private versions of public transit. The laws turned out to have very little effect on road safety. What worked was a second initiative where passengers on the minibuses were encouraged to quote, heckle and chide drivers for unsafe driving. Stickers on the buses said, don't just sit there, stand up, speak up. When consumers were encouraged to make some noise, driver behavior improved radically, and many bus crashes dropped by at least 50%. Now, we don't know what exactly drove this.
十几名乘客的小客车。它们是公共交通的私营版本。事实证明，这些法律对道路安全的改善收效甚微。真正起作用的是第二项举措：鼓励小巴乘客对司机的危险驾驶行为“进行起哄和责骂”。车内的贴纸写着：别光坐着，站起来，大声说出来。当消费者被鼓励发出一些声音时，司机的行为发生了根本性的改善，小巴撞车事故减少了至少50%。现在，我们不知道具体是什么促成了这一点。
Maybe people spoke up, maybe the driver was afraid people would speak up, whatever it was, it worked. That is extraordinary. And I also think that we should rename the show Heckle and Chide. You can be Heckle, I can be Chide. whatever it was, it worked. That is extraordinary. I also think that we should rename the show Heckle and Chide. You can be Heckle, I can be Chide. I actually think a lot of this shows power to the people. Can I be Dr Heckle and Mr Chide?
也许是人们发出了声音，也许是司机害怕人们发声，不管是什么原因，它确实起作用了。这太不可思议了。我也觉得我们应该把这个节目改名为《起哄与责骂》。你可以叫起哄，我可以叫责骂。不管是什么原因，它确实起作用了。这太不可思议了。我也觉得我们应该把这个节目改名为《起哄与责骂》。你可以叫起哄，我可以叫责骂。我实际上认为这个节目的很大一部分力量在于“权归于民”。我可以叫“起哄博士”和“责骂先生”吗？
Certainly. There you have it. Building new roads can lead to more congestion and banning people from driving can increase pollution. Traffic noise is not just unpleasant. It can have health consequences. lead to more congestion and banning people from driving can increase pollution. Traffic noise is not just unpleasant, it can have health consequences. Finally, before you pass a new law to solve a problem, try to empower the people with the problem to fix it themselves. Dan, thanks for joining me on Stappwadson.
当然可以。这就是全部内容。修建新道路可能会导致更严重的拥堵，而禁止人们开车则会加剧污染。交通噪音不仅令人不快，还会对健康产生影响。导致更严重的拥堵，而禁止人们开车则会加剧污染。交通噪音不仅令人不快，还会对健康产生影响。最后，在你通过新法律去解决某个问题之前，试着赋权给身处问题中的人们，让他们自己去解决。丹，谢谢你参加秒表科学节目。
My pleasure, I have to get back in my car now. The Hidden Brain podcast is produced by Cara McGurk-Kallison, Maggie Pennman and Max Nestrak. You can find us on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram and listen to my stories on your local public radio station. If you like this episode, please leave us a review on iTunes. It'll help other people find the podcast. I'm Shankar Veddhathan and this is NPR. I'm Shankar Vedantan and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我的荣幸，我现在得回车上去了。《隐藏的大脑》播客由卡拉·麦格克-卡利森、玛吉·彭曼和马克·内斯特拉克制作。你可以在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上找到我们，并在当地公共广播电台收听我的故事。如果你喜欢这期节目，请在iTunes上给我们留个好评。这能帮助其他人找到这个播客。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这里是NPR。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这里是NPR。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。